et
lui il arrive avec sa pub voilà il va
venir se mettre là qui valent le projet
là mais c'est très difficile qu'il le
prouvera que l'hypothèque à entasser y
en en faisant le mouvement neil elle
même elle
publie mais où est donc passée la 7ème
compagnie robert lamoureux se pose la
question est en fait un film avec pierre
mondy jean lefebvre
aldo maccione eric colin c'est
l'histoire de deux de trois soldats
français très très très moyens qui font
des choses très très très au-dessus de
la moyenne
moi je m'appelle louis chaudard dans le
civil je suis
gérant d'une quincaillerie à vesoul
et puis lors du repli stratégique de mai
au cours d'une mission d'observation je
fais partie d'une compagnie de
transmission mon capitaine m'envoie pour
observer si les allemands suivent ou
suivent pas alors je choisis deux
imbéciles je m'appelle pithiviers mou à
moi je suis depuis lors on observe on va
dans un cimetière puis
les allemands passent sur le chemin on a
enterré le film puis ce fils saad est à
refaire le fil du téléphone parce qu'on
est relié à la compagnie par un
téléphone qu'on a emporté avec nous la
compagnie à laquelle ils appartiennent
et en égard est faite prisonnière ils
vont descendre tout doucement voiliers
du haut de la carte au bas de la carte
ça va leur prendre 400 jours et ils vont
vivre confortablement ils vont emmener
ils vont se baigner ils vont aller à la
chasse pour leur compte et deux gardes à
la campagne ça ducharme entend les
oiseaux
les vaches et cochons
et puis ils font la rencontre d'un
lieutenant qui est un battant c'était
vraiment un héros de la guerre de 40 il
y en a eu et alors lui va les entraîner
dans des dans une espèce d'héroïsme
auquel il n'était pas destiné dans le
lieutenant il aime bien d'autant que
c'est le directeur dans la vie civile de
choudar puisque chaude en avant des
casseroles et que je perds du lieutenant
dire mon pea - fabrique les casseroles
c'est moi la voix lacoste au kilo
ils vont finir par être propriétaire
d'une dépanneuse allemande et alors avec
ça et
parce qu'il peut vraiment pas faire
autrement qu'être héros ils vont le
devenir à leur grande surprise
d'ailleurs c'est un bon film
en tout cas moi je suis de garde on est
toujours là elle est toujours vivante
s'est jamais tel qu'il est moche
alors qu'en deuxième bauges tassin la
mitrailleuse
la suite garde
je suis de garde et voyez malgré que
soit volleyeurs je suis bien avec mon
chef
la preuve quand je suis bien j'ai le
droit de fumer et jeumont fm que cela
qui fait 14 kg me
round
nous on s'en fout des allemands parce
que ils sont devant et nous on est
derrière alors vous pensez toujours
courir après nous on est derrière moi je
suis de garde
[Musique]